hey everybody happy vlogmas that's vlog
every day and Christmas now for me
vlogmas is I'm posting a video every day
sometimes it might not be a vlog because
I've got a couple of videos that I've
already filmed cooking videos and also
some vlogs that I have not posted like
the AMAs Thanksgiving I I mean it's
gonna be Christmas by the time I post my
Thanksgiving vlog I'm excited to attempt
to make a video every day in December
and there's a lot of stuff going on like
our parents are coming to visit can't
believe it hurry it'll be here again
Maddie got a bath this morning at 780
because he smelled so bad I was like
this pig is gross okay so he just went
potty outside and here's the problem
like he pees on himself how do we miss
mommy and so how do we get you to no pee
on yourself sweet baby he just did it
again let's see if we can see his teeth
show them look how big they are
oh my gosh no big Hardaway's water wait
wait to be tweet to be shoot it a little
bit yeah when we feed him breakfast
don't feed I missed more times that I
have Noah I was probably like 8 o'clock
we should give a little snack we've been
teaching him pot let's see if he
remembers sit yes good boy okay ready
plug pop yes good boy he's a prodigy
right pop yes oh my god I'm so proud his
face right paw yes oh boy you guys know
that we started doing this last night
and we did it and he's he's brilliant
he's so smart smart dog good boy okay
take this back okay home you can just
set it down I'm gonna continue our
training put mix things up down down yes
ho baby you're just brilliant you're so
smart it makes me so hot
look at her
just had a really lovely time at the
Apple store got it got a few items
seized you got her phone all hooked up
and Jenna's out here with the Beast
oh boy well I think that I have
developed some sort of like joint issue
that holy facts soon do I mean so what
was so massive oh the babe is so cute
under them kisses overall I just unbox
something so exciting so you guys
probably have seen before that I've
talked about Percy and Poppleton they're
my absolute favorite pigs on the
internet and they came out with some
prissy and pop mini pig stuffed animals
stuffed pig they're stuffed pigs and
they're them they're so adorable like I
can't believe it look at this this is
when their little wedding pictures even
in the brother/sister but that's okay oh
my heart my heart is just I can't even
handle this like look how cute is our
little little birthmark Oh what do you
think of the piggies on that decile
pretty lick be sweet be sweet oh my gosh
I am so proud of these pigs I like I
love them so much I let's put a link in
the description if you guys want to get
yourself a little pig or get somebody
else a peg for Christmas or the holidays
or whatever it is that you celebrate
let's let's celebrate everyone I'm
celebrating some pigs and we also have
another little present for the pup this
is for the upstairs office because I
wanted him great color scheme I wanted
him to have a little place Jay oh my god
perfect baby
oh now you might not like the pillow
even like you know like it you can watch
it oh look at this one pockets in the
back and boy you're free he already is
into it oh oh you gotta be careful do
you like it oh he's into it he's big he
is better to be Manny that's your
natural ash couch man look what up now
here Manny Manny down okay not that type
it down I'm right hmm we're gonna have
to get him to like it it's cute I also
got a little like toy chest for him
that's Brianne told me to get that for
him so I owe you like the paper before
she
did you try to rip those buttons off
this is going really well
everybody Happy Thanksgiving so we just
had a meeting of the pups and I was like
guys we gotta let him off the leash we
gotta let them do their thing
and guess what they're doing their thing
hi Maddie honey did you want a pet did
you want a pet oh you guys are being so
good I'm so proud they like don't really
like play play they just kind of sniff
and chill you want sniffing gel later
Oh Maddie I love you so much oh they're
so funny
Maddie you ready to go me Bella Maddie
isn't that a baby a dog another dog now
the third dog on the trip that you're
gonna meet are you excited
he's like I looks excited he's so tired
this poor little beast oh look at the
baby oh gosh you're giving kisses you
give kisses my mom oh my gosh is she
cute oh hey guys happy Black Friday
worked sort of going shopping
but only because American Eagle has dog
clothes and I want to go get some
matching outfits for Maddie and for
myself of course and then we have to
take a little bow to the vet I feel like
that's where we spend most of our time
nowadays do I get shotgun no I'm going
to take the back so that I can control
the music kindly it's not that busy here
because Missy will do their shopping
online now I got a black sweater and a
Christmas tree sweatshirt so I'm I'm
ready for the holidays
maybe I'll wear to look like him so I'm
trying to find a dress for the video
game awards but I am unable to I can't I
can't shut this and he shot the dress I
don't know if I like it maybe we
shouldn't even shove it what do you know
it's not good too big I look like a cute
no basic thanks Jen
the dress needs to be the mood happy buh
buh buh buh buh look at your little peg
leg from his little okay little is low
hospital visit everyone oh yeah
whoa watch your watch a pause excuse you
excuse you let me go away okay it's so
cold
crying back to LA yeah your daddy please
I beg you go and mady's 500 Madi
this isn't your seat honey this isn't
your seat you have to go in your bag you
know this is where you go yes thank you
one terminal over seven a Matt and Matt
and a Jenna hi
we made it I'm not sure what this vlog
all contains I think it's pretty much
all of Thanksgiving and whatever else
it's probably just a lot of puppies I'm
exhausted I'm going to go home and sleep
daddy the belted out here say hello it's
me say hello from the other side